welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on how the multiple
timelines of the multiverse can be cut
up glued back together and stylized with
some glitter and painted macaroni like
an arts and crafts project you made at
summer camp my name is mt and i'm here
today with off-screen producer bradley
what's going on brandon hello mt what's
our big question for today brandon okay
mt with confirmation that the marvel
series from netflix much beloved are
coming to disney plus on march 16th we
have to wonder if these series are ever
going to be accepted into the broader
mcu as part of its canon come on isn't
the tent big enough bring them in bring
them in i want my hellcat man i want my
trish walker hellcat in the midnight
suns let's go oh no i know so i mean at
first you're all probably sitting at
your computers or looking at your phones
thinking like heck no this is never
gonna happen but if you dive a little
deeper maybe there's a little trickier
answer than you might think and it all
leads us to this week's big question
sorry scrolling scrolling how will
marvel how will the marvel netflix
series fit into the broader mcu ah yes i
like this question because it's true
that back in the days before disney plus
marvel studios lent out some of their
precious ip abc made shows like agent
carter and humans and agents of shield
hulu had runaways fx had legion and all
of them were marvel characters but
pretty much existed outside of the main
mcu canon except for you know agent
carter which seems to have been brought
into the fold with jarvis showing up in
endgame as we remember but perhaps the
most beloved of these marvel side
stories were those of a set of heroes
that operated in and around new york
city these were daredevil jessica jones
luke cage and iron fist who would later
team up to become the defenders as well
as everyone's favorite vigilante with a
skull on his shirt the punisher but
while so many of these shows were
beloved by fans of the mcu kevin feige
was pretty clear that these were not mcu
canon as recently as 2019 around the
time of the launch of disney plus and
the announcement of some new marvel
series appearing on the streaming
platform feige was quoted as saying
disney plus is going to give us this
opportunity to tell even deeper stories
about characters you already know and
love for the first time we'll
interrelate so this pretty much confirms
that what we had come before wasn't
interlinked with the main mcu timeline
and therefore wasn't canon but now that
these netflix series are coming home to
disney plus could feige be changing his
tune so let's start with what seems to
be the biggest potential inclusion the
one that everybody cares about our
favorite blind brother daredevil
one of the biggest surprises we got
early in spider-man no way home was the
appearance of our favorite lawyer our
good lawyer matt murdock
preventing bricks from causing people to
have uh concussions um very nice man um
i hope they paid him extra but let's be
real peter's a broke ass [ __ ] yeah do
you do does your look does your lawyer
bill you if he stops you from getting
like hit in the head with a brick does
that get added on i think sophie yeah
yeah we threw in an extra billable hour
because i caught a brick and saved you
from a lifetime of uh cte so you're
welcome he just builds you like whatever
the hospital would have built
that's a lot but what's but yeah his
adeptness with catching an errant brick
that came flying through the window
confirms that this matt murdock is
imbued with the ability to make him the
daredevil so this of course happened the
same week that vincent d'onofrio showed
up as kingpin once again on the kate
bishop program as i like to call it but
other people call it hawkeye a series
that took place around the same time as
the events of spiderman no way home with
even that little uh that same area
showing up in the final swing yeah yeah
seeing rockefeller center with the ice
skating rink and the christmas tree i
love that area nice memories there a lot
of shrunken uh suit jacket people the
horrific death of a of a bro real mafia
member who gets eaten by an owl jesus
christ
dark
dark death by owl i mean oh my god
owls are pretty deadly i mean matt
reeves is talking about the batman
sequel being a court of owls so you know
it's the season for owls you know what
i'm saying who knows who knows
[Laughter]
so this would seem to confirm that at
least daredevil was being brought into
the main mcu cannon but is this the same
daredevil or a variant i think you know
the easiest answer right is that these
are variants of both
matt murdock and kingpin right they've
got to be variants and this is uh right
after loki basically spelled out for the
mcu like hey we can show the same
character a hundred times and have them
be a hundred different versions of it
there's infinite timelines infinite
variance they can look the same they can
look different that's gotta be it right
i just feel like daredevil as a series
on netflix a lot of the things that
happened might be a little bit too rough
for the main
disney fight mcu to sort of
dive into both kingpin and uh uh
daredevil played by vince d'onofrio and
charlie cox respectively were the most
beloved of these netflix heroes would
five you kind of put out that statement
that was like yeah it's all they're not
it's not ever gonna be canon everyone
was kind of like uh really but like
these two they're like come on please at
least these two even if these are
variants the audience at least
understands the motivations of these
characters in the same way that like you
don't have to do a spider-man origin
story anymore because everyone knows how
spider-man originated you don't have to
do it as much with these characters
because you could be like well if you
really want to know what their backstory
is go check out you know the the series
that are now on disney plus that once
we're on netflix do you think empty that
this daredevil and this kingpin in the
mcu know each other yet have they had
any interaction yet or do you think
they're they're gonna meet for the first
time all over again given how hawkeye
ended and like given that whole showdown
and knowing that we know that daredevil
is in the area
i just find it weird that he didn't show
up because like it seemed like a really
big thing that happened maybe we have a
matt murdock that hasn't really had
interaction with wilson fix maybe he's
at his beginning stages like we see you
know the yeah the new batman movie if
they are going the route of making this
a new version of the character it would
be really smart for kevin feige to do
that or just like sort of just
reintroduce their conflict and just sort
of just cement it like yeah i know you
guys already saw this because this is a
different universe like you're seeing a
new origin story yeah when they
introduced kingpin on the hawkeye series
you know he at first looked the same he
was wearing a suit but then he's like
hawaiian shirt kingpin and he's working
in a garage he's not working in like a
very fancy office he doesn't seem quite
the same as the kingpin we move from the
netflix series i mean i would love if
you know sure this daredevil and kingpin
have been in the background of the mcu
the whole time it's not the same ones
you saw on netflix but they've been in
the background these characters and
maybe they were building up to a meeting
but maybe like kingpin got blipped like
how great would it be if like you know
daredevil was on the case he was looking
who was funding all these crimes and the
kids in in hell's kitchen and just as he
burst into kingdom's office like that's
when the snap happened and he was like
hello
[Music]
and then five five years goes by and he
forgets all about that character because
he's no longer showing his influence
daredevil's got to deal with a new york
city that's going through you know the
the blip uh and then five years later
you know kingpin comes back and he's got
to start all over again like his whole
empire's gone and i think that's a great
motivation for him like he's so pissed
he was on top of the world and he gets
flipped away and now the world's totally
different he's like no no i gotta build
up from the bottom again and i'll do it
because i'm the kingpin vanessa
you just got away from me you took
everything first time actually brent i
think that's a super great idea i would
love that scenario because it makes a
lot of sense but i actually think
kingpin was alive during it
you just have to say that you're fine
and you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it because they would
never understand ronan kills echo's
father who was working for kingpin right
and and he got ticked off sort of
orchestrated
you might be right empty but who cares
right just write the stories make them
fun who cares yeah because you mentioned
how you know agent carter i think has
pretty much been believed to have been
absorbed fully into the mcu you know
agents of shield was supposed to be part
of the mcu they were very much in the
beginning you know they had like nick
fury show up and lady siff and maria
hill but then they were like yeah this
is the fcu anymore because shield's full
of hydra but we like having it's just a
shield so we have to keep doing this
show i know it's our job to help this
guy and everything but i think this
guy's a lost cause with netflix they
were like maybe one day they'll bring us
in and so they kept very broad language
but yeah i think maybe they had a battle
of new york that was very different
maybe it didn't involve the shotari i
think you're right that it's it's still
kind of separate i really would love if
they established that daredevil had just
been there the whole time and they just
never called on his help because he was
busy dealing with hell's kitchen but
i think this is a variant daredevil and
a bearing uh kingpin
[Music]
is it even possible to bring in one
netflix character without the others
given how connected their series were on
netflix these shows were designed to be
in such a way that you know you had like
characters showing up on on multiple
shows you had the night nurse character
played by rosario dawson who showed up
in like all of them and then showed up
in the defenders jessica jones like
killed uh someone who worked with luke
cage in the prison like it was all very
very interconnected but i don't know if
you could fully bring one of these
netflix series characters without it you
know everyone hanging on being like no
i'm there too you're gonna drag me in
too
we we talked to each other on the show
you gotta bring me in it would be
interesting if they somehow found a way
to do that especially with all this
multiverse of madness stuff you know uh
the comics had to deal with this right
marvel comics had to deal with this
problem they had where they had so many
different universes and timelines and
books that they just smashed them all
together and reshuffled the deck and
said like okay these are your heroes now
all the other universes are dead who
cares um so
it would be weird
and very fun if they found a way in
multiverse of madness to like just pluck
out a few characters and be like no this
story this is the same jessica jones you
saw
on netflix but we've pulled her out of
her universe and plopped her into the
mcu like that would be really
fascinating i would really love if they
were to do that because like a lot of
people would appreciate that and i feel
like a secret war scenario would
definitely open the doors and just be
like hey i have mcu daredevil oh yeah
let's team up and fight together in this
really long hallway two big hallways
from different universes the longest
coming together charlie cox clearing two
checks on that day now let's put a pivot
on over to another three season series
on netflix jessica jones my girl kirsten
ritter with the leather jacket and the
jeans but this was another fan favorite
that a lot of people hope would be
pulled into the mcu and one of the
biggest challenges into bringing the
series into the main canon would
potentially be the conflict of a major
villain from season 2 would cause in
that season the show introduced dr carl
malus as the person that imbued jessica
jones and her mother with the superhuman
abilities and in the comics dr carl
malus works with the power broker at
power broker incorporated given that
falcon and the winter soldier introduced
sharon carter as the power broker could
this potential conflict prevent jessica
jones from ever coming over like full
stop we were all kind of wondering
when we were watching falcon winter
soldier and like they were teasing the
power broker like could they just bring
over dr carl malus and be like this is
it you know this is the same guy and
that probably would have been a super
fun idea uh but they didn't do that i'm
sure they have a great plan for sharon
carter as the power broker i think
you're right that we'll see you in like
armor wars i think the fact that there
was already like a power broker even
though i don't think believe they ever
said the words power broker on that
series but it was pretty heavily implied
it was like sort of like a similar type
of vibe to what they would introduce
involved in the winter soldier with you
know right of the superpower program
being worked and like people getting
superpowers it would make sense that if
the super soldier serum exists there
would be multiple people trying to
recreate it constantly especially if you
can get your hands on like if there's
still blood floating around it seems
like every couple of years they discover
a new safe that has blood inside of it
and they're like oh look more more blood
hooray yeah yeah it would be sense that
there's a bunch of different companies
making knockoff serums and if sharon
carter is this criminal mastermind and
realizes there is a power broker out
there uh who gets killed by jessica
jones she could then slide in and be
like no i'm the power broker now and
that just adds to more confusion about
who it really is and who's really behind
all these programs or maybe you know
sharon carter is overseeing every
version of the power broker every group
that's trying to recreate the super
soldier serum she's like in charge of
that it's like her own syndicate of all
these different scientists trying to
make super soldier here
super soldier serums uh super soldier
serums super soldiers here super soldier
syrups that's like our whole deal now is
like just trying to find the best way to
recreate it but hey is jessica jones the
recipient of the super soldier serum in
the mcu though
do are you asking if i think she's a
what we would qualify as a super soldier
she's on the level of captain america
and on the level of um the winter
soldier and bucky and all that stuff
um i think yeah i think you got to call
her a super soldier they never say those
words on jessica jones as far as i
remember i think she is a super soldier
i think she's got the same kind of juice
especially after what we've seen with
the flag smashers right like you can get
get the power without the muscles you
don't always need the muscles anymore i
love that comparison with the flax
smashers because like i never really
thought about it but like when the flag
specials were moving and like fighting
they kind of felt like jessica jones a
little bit like street
they were dressed like regular people
just fighting with superpowers so like
yeah i would definitely call jessica
jones a super soldier because of you
know she got a type of serum and she got
juiced up got super soldier to me i
don't know
i love that and i think like of a lot of
these characters like she's the easiest
one to bring over so i think she makes
the most sense as someone who just like
slips right in like she never got into
these big crazy fights with villains you
know she was always lurking kind of on
very small scale doing her private
investigator thing i think it'd be very
easy to explain like yeah she's been
there the whole time you didn't notice
her you know because she's just dealing
with much smaller stuff much smaller
stuff yeah she's just doing no private
investigating and no big deal i really
want to see jessica jones cameo and
she-hulk i would love because i love it
it'd be perfect private investigator
lawyer both strong women let's go come
on kevin what could happen let's go
let's go but next up on the
consideration docket we have luke cage
because this show got two seasons on
netflix and introduced a whole host of
characters and criminals from the luke
cage comics shout out to bushmaster one
of my favorite villains i just thought
he was a really cool dude just the way
he moved and like i don't know
one of the biggest conflicts here might
be the double casting that would be
taking place should this series come to
mcu canon land because of course
mahershala ali played cottonmouth on
luke cage expertly one of the greatest
film performances i've ever seen in the
mcu also shout out to your boy shades
shades but now mahershala ali is booked
to be blade and alfred woodard was of
course mariah dillard and she was also
miriam sharp the grieving mother who
confronts tony stark but does double
casting really matter in the mcu as
gemma chan has portrayed both cersei in
eternals and minerva in captain marvel
so like can it happen should it happen i
mean people look similar right mt we all
have our weird doppelgangers out in the
world uh this is true
and spoiler alert if you haven't watched
uh luke cage but cottonmouth doesn't
make it through the whole first season i
don't think it's a conflict it's not
like blade's ever gonna run into
cottonmouth you know uh
you know frankly there was such good
world building in luke cage and such a
vast array of diverse characters i think
it's really a shame that the mcu doesn't
bring them all in you know and gemma
champlain two characters you know
minerva was like a pretty small
character in captain marvel plus she was
an alien who looked completely different
you know so
it doesn't cause as much confusion for
people i think you know blade and
cottonmouth looking very similar might
be
tough for people to get past but i i
don't think casting should stop uh the
mcu from pulling these things out people
just are really excited to see these
characters as part of the right oh my
god that looks just like cod bath who
really cares at the end of the day like
there was a purple man with rainbow
stones and you know nothing really makes
sense anymore tiana's sticking out of
the water over there okay well exactly
like his head is like
okay now
i guess if i look like a little place
i'm a vampire
next we have the punisher because i
think the main thing that would keep the
punisher from joining the main mcu
timeline has got to be the extreme
graphic violence associated with frank
[Applause]
castle because we've yet to have like an
r-rated mcu film and unless kevin feige
is ready to get super super dark i don't
think we'll be seeing this one anytime
soon but yeah what do you think i don't
think the mcu wants the punisher at all
i mean the show was a lot of fun it was
fine it's fun to have these like moments
of like graphic violence within all this
comic book stuff like that's what makes
like suicide squad and peacemaker a lot
of fun right it's oh it's like a r rated
more adult heavy stuff but i just don't
even see how
frank castle comes into the mcu uh even
in the comic books right now they've
kind of tweaked punisher a little bit
he's got like a new logo you know
because i think the skull logo whatever
you think of it gets gets used by
different groups out there in our world
for better or for worse so i don't know
if the mcu really wants to get into all
that and the punisher you know as a
character has evolved over the years to
try and address the issues that that
character brings up i i do not see kevin
feige touching the punisher let alone
any version of the punishment a sickness
that sneaks in through the cracks the
way that brussels sprouts sneak onto a
plate of delicious macaroni and cheese i
don't care with netflix or whatever i
don't think the mcu wants to deal with
the punisher i think they're just like
no thank you
that's not a knock on the comics they're
fun read them read whatever you want so
smart me
enjoy books so much i just don't think
it fits into the mcu that we know and
love right now yeah
if we were to see the punisher i think
it would have to be a punisher
that was very much you know a villain
like presented as a villain at first
right and probably has like very
drastically different motivations than
what we've seen probably in the comics
and even the netflix series the best way
for marvel to do this and this is going
to sound wild but like put them in space
like if you shoot aliens it's fine yeah
put it out there with the guys in the
galaxy okay yo straight up like put
punisher in space make him like a space
bounty hunter or whatever i don't know
i'm not a body hunter but like a space
psycho and like having them shoot aliens
who cares if aliens die get them off our
planet we don't need them here who cares
if much aliens gotta die
i mean like obviously like i care if
aliens die but like you get more of a
pass to kill
alien looking people than you know
people-looking people because you can
attach yourself i totally agree with
that uh eternals two it starts harry
styles comes walking down the hallway
and he's like hey i got someone else to
come with us and it's frank castle baby
we're gonna go shoot
in the skull
we're shooting this one
that's a free one for you kevin feige
cosmic revenge nothing like it really
but hey when it comes to iron fist i
think the biggest thing that might keep
it from coming into the main mcu might
be the events of shanxi because that
would have been the easiest way to
include iron fist into mcu cannon but it
never really happened because you know
and jessica henwick who played the
character colleen wing on iron fist
stated that she was actually offered the
role of xi ling in chiang chi in the
legend of the ten rings but turned it
down in the hopes that she would be able
to reprise her role as colleen wing so
perhaps there's a possibility that the
iron fist story could be brought up into
a sequel to chongqi but we'd have to
wait and see you know this is a
difficult one and i love what they did
in shanghai it would make sense for like
iron fist and shangchi to meet up just
because of their
you know uh martial arts backgrounds and
their fighting styles and kind of that
mysticism you got to give it to jessica
henwick for like sticking to her guns
and be like no i want to play calling
wing i don't want you honestly jessica
henwick is the best part of the iron
fist series she's phenomenal i think
that she needs to be in the mcu as a
like permanent staple so like if she
wants to come back as if we can
implement colleen wing especially with
the way that iron fist season two ended
yeah it was gonna be a show where iron
fist and his his buddies travel around
like kung fu doing good fighting baddies
kind of getting out of new york city i
think it would be really cool to include
it in the shanghai sequel just be like
hey we ran into this guy and look what
the powers he's got but yeah i don't
know if that actor is ready to get into
it all he got a lot of criticism he got
a lot of heat it seemed like he really
liked the character and like the show
but you're totally right yeah i hope
that they bring back jessica henrik's
cause like she was awesome yeah i think
both finn jones and jessica henwick
deserve another shot at both of their
roles when these actors first sign up to
these roles they don't want to do a bad
job and like everyone wants to do their
best like do their best so like if
there's an opportunity for a second
chance for people to really love iron
fist
because it's in a different universe i
say give it to him why not like let's
just see if we can make it work but also
i am a proponent of an asian iron fist
so let's just cast an agenda i think
i think that would be great and you know
i love what they did with shang chi it
looks so different it felt so different
a lot of the fighting styles that we saw
in that film yeah bring bring iron fist
into that world and expand it even more
let's go you don't belong here i'm danny
rand now that we have it all laid out
what do you think the likelihood is of
the netflix series being brought as
canon into the main mcu brandon i think
as it is entirely very small very small
chance
not gonna happen no not gonna happen
but i do think there's an opportunity
yes we're gonna see variants i think
you're definitely gonna see variants but
i think there is an opportunity to bring
at least one or two of the same
characters as they are get brought over
from the netflix series and put into the
main mcu you know whether that's through
some multiversal shenanigans whether
that's through a little sling ring
portal whether that's through
whatever happened in spider-man no way
home you know bring bring one or two of
them over and be like how did i get here
where am i where's my home
how did i get here you know and just
have to be forced to live in the mcu uh
and make their way through it i think it
would be really cool and a really fun
way to incorporate some of these
characters what about umt i share very
similar views like i think that
the netflix series probably won't be
canon like 100 i think that a lot of the
stuff that happened in the netflix
series could be brought over as canon
the people
need to be reminded
that the city belongs to me
but i just think that you know kevin
feige wants to
just tell his own story but like you
said if there's an opportunity for no
way hope situation to open up so we can
just see those characters again as they
were in the netflix series let's get it
i think feige's gonna pull one scroll
fake out on us too we're gonna see like
you know jessica jones walking down the
street really like oh it's krista ritter
it's jessica jones that someone's going
to shoot her in the head she's going to
like turn into a scroll and be like all
right oh my god kevin feige screw you
kevin feige my heart would be broken
he's going to do it he's going to do a
scroll fake out that would be like the
biggest because jessica jones is like
the most like i i hate all this like
superhero [ __ ] i had all this weird [ __ ]
type of person so if she was subscribed
be like wow i trust none of you people
none of you people but hey time is
running out on grabbing the batman
inspired latest obsession shirt over at
new rockstarsmerch.com there's a limited
supply of the cool gotham noir design so
grab one quick before it disappears back
into the shadows like batman and before
we dive into our bite size questions
next some words from the people that
help bring us big question to you people
like masterclass because with
masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace you can learn how to
write from malcolm gladwell how to play
chess from gary kasparov or how to learn
how to make beats from timbaland with
over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors that thing that
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think for film and tv fans like
the staff at new rockstars masterclass
has a really cool variety of classes to
take you can take directing classes from
spike lee or werner hersog acting
classes from natalie portman or samuel
jackson or even get into screenwriting
and storytelling with neil gaiman which
is dope and the classes are beautifully
shot and edited so they're engaging and
interesting to watch and the lessons are
broken up into short digestible sections
you can polish off a few cooking classes
with gordon ramsay on your phone tv or
computer while you wait for the next new
rockstars video to upload we highly
recommend that you check it out and get
unlimited access to every master class
and as a big question audience member
you get 15 off an annual membership so
go to masterclass.com
bigquestionnow that's
masterclass.com bigquestion for 15 off
master class check it out we're super
busy right now at new rock stars with no
sign of things slowing down in the near
future online shopping isn't slowing
down anytime soon either either either
is your business ready to keep up with
the pace with shipstation you'll never
worry about shipping again make the
switch to handle all your shipping needs
quickly affordably and painlessly
shipstation is already trusted by over
100 000 e-commerce sellers you can track
orders from any sales channel easily
find the best shipping carrier with
deeply discounted rates and automate
shipping tasks with just a few clicks we
really appreciate how much time
shipstation saves us when we need to
ship things it frees up time so we can
use it to make more content or you know
re-watch all of jessica jones again
we love jessica jones we gotta keep
watching it don't make her a scroll
kevin yeah take it all back 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business that's how great it
is ship more in less time with
shipstation use our offer code
bigquestion to get a 60-day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress-free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type big
question no space in between big
question ship station make ship happen
but now everybody it's time for our
favorite part of the show is the bite
size questions
questions
now
my friend brad are you ready for this
one i'm ready i'm ready for mt our
friend hyde didworm on discord asks
did thanos first snap dust any eternals
on earth or any other planets or the
celestials
hide the worm huh well that's a
fantastic question my friend we often
forget that thanos's actions affected
not only the life on earth but
throughout the entire cosmos i mean it
was probably
insanely weird for a lot of planets who
had no idea what was going on with
thanos
or the infinity stones to just one day
like everyone disappeared and then one
day five years later everyone came back
and they were like what the hell is
going on
what is this there's probably some crazy
religions that came about because of
this it's probably oh yeah
i would probably guess that whole thing
happening in a freaking mood night
with the staff
yeah like there's a if you had no idea
what was going on you were like what is
happening
um but what about the celestials and the
eternals huh were they immune from
thanos's actions let's start with the
eternals and thankfully eric eisenberg a
reporter for cinema blend asked
eternal's director chloe zao this exact
question and she had a pretty
interesting take on the quandary he
asked her if the eternals lost any
members during the blip and she said
well i can't say this out loud but if
you think about it if you think about
what the celestials told them if you
think about what the celestials told
them about themselves technically they
can't get blipped that's what she said
that's what she said i can't get back
uh so there's two big things to take
away from this quote number one she said
she couldn't say it out loud which means
she's either speaking well beyond the
bounds of the mcu canon she's a logic
create or
she's letting out a secret story detail
that would be part of eternals too
either way filmmakers for the mcu such
as the russo brothers have been allowed
to clarify points of canon post-film so
we should accept that as canon for now
she says they can't get blip they can't
get blipped number two this is the
important thing to take away uh the
non-organic nature of the eternals
because they're androids it kind of kept
them exempt from thanos's little
infinity stone spell right he's trying
to wipe out half the life in the
universe aka living sentient beings if
the eternals technically aren't living
then it would seem that they're safe
from what thanos
had done you know that's pretty simple
plus i think in the eternals when they
were talking about the blip someone
would have mentioned like yeah and i was
gone for five years too you know they
didn't say that they were just sitting
around chatting so they're just
heartless robots who were safe from
everything thanos did and did nothing to
help they did nothing now rude get these
eternals off my planet if i was dane
whitman and i was dating cersei i'd be
like ah
he is so nice to me
you should be like i mean you look nice
but you should have helped
like are you serious like come on man
bruh come on bro
bro that would at least cause at least a
couple of relationship arguments on my
part
[Laughter]
she's like why didn't you wash the
dishes why didn't you help fight thanos
i don't know
before you go
like how long how long do you think dave
whitman waits before he goes on like
another date this is a fight size within
the right size question
he knows that she's an eternal and that
she's a robot and then she's lived for
like 5 000 years
so like i think he's allowed to go on a
date
pretty quickly after she disappeared
right i mean
i
wanda
it took her a little bit to get over her
android so maybe that's different that's
completely different it's completely
different empty
had to watch her love get
destroyed by thanos
come back to life killed again
then sees then she disappears comes back
has to fight thanos immediately doesn't
even see her husband's body her love's
body then she sees it all cut up on a
table dane whitman's just had a park and
cersei disappears he's allowed to go on
a date a week later i think a week i
give him a week but like is cersei even
a girlfriend at that point a lot of
questions you can even you can be raised
because like is she a person like are
you dating a person it's like with wanda
was wanda dating a person in a vision
that's a whole staff
how dare you he's gotta you gotta he's
gotta in my heart they're both
everybody's people anyway we wrapped up
that bite size now we're back to the
main bite size uh what about the
celestials okay we covered the eternals
they can't be blipped but what about
these uh celestials the film uh eternals
did establish that the celestials
existed before the infinity stones uh
and then they may have in fact been the
ones to create the infinity stones in
the comic books some some story lines
have said that like the celestials
created the infinity stones but it's not
yet fully laid out in maine mcu canon
that it was the celestials who made the
infinity stones but if they if they did
make the infinity stones i would think
they would put in a si a failsafe that
would kind of like prevent them from
being used against them you know what i
mean like we're gonna make infinity
stones they're gonna be super powerful
but you can't use them against us so
that makes me think that they didn't
create the infinity stones because i
think they exist beyond the celestials
uh because the comics have shown that
like the infinity stones are very
powerful and can be used against
celestials
but
whatever whatever you think about the
celestials creating the infinity stones
or not
i don't think any of them got blipped i
don't think it was possible for them to
get blipped given the fact that if if a
celestial had gotten like
blipped away by thanos i think they
would have reacted immediately catch me
i thought how about that instead they
just like let thanos do his thing right
you know thanos snaps his little purple
fingers
nothing happens to the celestials
they're like oh we're fine this is cool
i mean it picks up the birth of you know
tiamet for a little bit but they're
celestial they delayed the timeline a
little bit
five years to them is nothing it's
nothing yeah it's literally like all
right like i got a little bit of a like
a five minute like not a five minute
delay but like a 30 second delay almost
like all right that's no big deal i can
i can wait 30 seconds
because like they're such long-lived
creatures so yeah i would definitely
agree that if you know thanos snap would
have done anything they would have shown
up immediately like they showed up at
the end of your turn it was like what's
going on here well
you're messing things up um so thanos
definitely knows about the celestial
she's aware of their existence so i
think he's smart enough to not mess with
them he was like i just need to wipe out
some people and then go live on my farm
yeah i don't i'm not trying to make it
honestly
i honestly feel like his knowledge of
the celestials it's sort of what drove
him mad he's like yo like i know that
there is a certain like law to the
cosmos and we're sort of going off of
that law so i'm going to work in
conjunction with the celestials and not
do anything to piss them off
so
they would actually love me they would
give me employee of the month
i still think that thanos was trying to
stop some emergences you know he knew
that like if i wipe out the life in the
universe it'll stop new celestials from
coming about or at least slow it down a
little bit
but
i'm not gonna mess with any living
celestials because they'll they'll come
for me real fast and they'll they'll
mess me up don't mess me up
that messed me up pretty good i don't
know if i can go uh yeah one-on-one with
uh
not near a show
i try to do that no now brandon who was
the first super villain to appear in a
comic book you know if we go back to the
history books you know there's a lot of
villains out there in the comics
throughout time and there were like you
know comic strips that appeared in like
newspapers before like comic books
really got going but i think if we want
to take a true comic book super villain
came in june of 1939 in action comics
number 13. you of course know action
comics this is where superman came from
in actor comics number 13 we meet ultra
humanite uh he was a foil of the beloved
superman of course he's the opposite of
superman in every way essentially he's a
criminal mastermind with super advanced
uh intellect uh and a not so powerful
body you know he's like kind of confined
to a wheelchair uh but he precedes even
lex luthor as a major villain for
superman like once lex luthor showed up
he kind of took the reigns but ultra
humanite was like the first major
villain uh and thanks to his advanced
intellect he's been able to survive over
the years mainly by transplanting his
brain into new bodies since he's so
smart he's able to do this without the
transplantation ever being rejected
that's super convenient huh way to be
smart buddy his goals already always
pretty much the same this is basic super
villain stuff domination of the world
you know if you're the first super
villain the first thing you got to do is
dominate the world uh i mean he's
showing up throughout
you got to set that bar you got to you
got to say this is what super villains
do okay we dominate
um he's shown how he's shown up
throughout time in dc comics from the
golden age the silver age to post-crisis
and he's even in the new 52 where he
appeared as a creature from the phantom
zone uh and then he also appeared he
transferred his brain into an albino
gorilla in dc rebirth
you know if you're gonna go for a strong
body go for a gorilla um so that's a
pretty solid run from comics for a super
villain i'm glad to see that they're
still showing up way to pay respects uh
to the og sv
ultra humanite that is walk i had no
idea that ultra humonite was the first
ever villain because like our first
major supervillain ever appear in comics
yeah i remember seeing him as a kid in
the justice league series um so like
it's just weird to know that he was the
first ever super villain so thank you
ultra humber knight um i thought that
his name is like basically be like
another version of superman ultra human
knife
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect yeah i mean that is that is the
most quintessential 1930s super villain
name his ultra humanite he had to do
damage
that's like they're like how do we make
another a foil for superman who's got an
idea ultra ignite what's even more than
super
but now it's time for our box of scraps
oh that box are scrapped you better get
to the back of the space brandon what
character from any genre or franchise
would you love to see appear in the main
mcu canon just go wild this is kevin
feige he's throwing the bag he's got all
that disney money to toss around he's
like i'm gonna bring in something that's
gonna rock people's minds this would be
a lot of fun like this would be my
childhood dreams come true if they
somehow they open up a portal just like
in spider-man nowhere home you see a
shadowy figure coming coming towards the
portal and it crosses into our universe
but it's not a human size it's it's
gigantic okay and what is it it's a
megazord that's right here come the
power rangers baby
oh my god oh my god i love you brandon
heck yeah all five of them they're in
the bodies and then tommy comes over too
just for a good time so we get the
grievances as well i want those og
dinosaur i want him in the mcu not not
the reboot stuff i don't want to see the
rebooted movie it was fun whatever i
wanna see the og stuff i want them to
have yeah outfits i wanted to do the
goofy punching you know what i mean
that's what i want in my main mcu shang
chu too book it shanxi versus the power
rangers let's go
bro i was thinking about saying that one
but i'm glad you did so thank you so
much pounder's name two would be bananas
bananas like they would fit in very well
but i was actually gonna choose another
uh team from my childhood we gotta go
for the teenage mutant ninja turtles oh
yes because my goodness they would fit
so well in the daredevil side of the
universe and like with everything going
on with like you know um the mutants
being introduced into the mcu
just make mutants turtles why not let's
put like literally make the mutants i
honestly am very shocked that disney
hasn't made a move on the ninja turtles
yet because
i mean not that they're for sale and
like they would be very expensive but
like they would make her super great fit
to the mcu just saying just saying
viacom is holding on to the turtles as
hard as this is true they're like you're
not taking these away from us the
turtles and the daredevil teaming up to
fight the hand in the foot it just makes
so much sense i love it it would be
great i would love to see
kingpin and shredder
a crazy like a mash imagine a mash-up of
kingpin and shredder
just like a really big shredder we got
that in a teenage mutant ninja turtles
too the secret of the use we got that
roided out shredder baby true but that
is it for this episode of big question i
want to thank brandon as always for
joining me on this episode follow him at
green and barrack that is an order
follow him at twitter at griddenberric
on twitter and follow me at
mastertainment on twitter follow new
rockstars here on youtube thank you guys
so much for spending time with us and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye bye
[Music]
you